今日のお昼は
[音楽]
いや全然置いてねー
dic パッケ京都して遊戯王の大会に入っててめちゃくちゃ急いでってサンドイッ杖
を食べたような気がします
ちなみに大会は4層いっぱいでした組んでミーナ無限蓮月ハードな3 d 食感グミ月
乃助六ゲル連携つかんでみーなというふうに皆さん知ってますか
なんか凄い食感が方いかんでみーなって組があるんですけどもうねそれのパクリん
パクリではないからそれのパクリではないんですけど組んでミーナというあの
カンデミーナってあーくんで皆を組み立てるの君っていう意味で無限蓮月組んでいいん
だという文がありましたこの早速開けてみたい所であるんですけどもなんかです無限
連携って書いてるわけですよ無限非常に重い言葉です
んなんかすごい形がすごいなんかアキュラこのパーツみたいな
見た目ですねこれなんか連携させてくれるらしいんですよで好きなと無限連結という
ことはこれこれ立つん会はめげに連結できるんじゃね
というわけで今回訓練みんなを100買ってみました
と言いたいところなんですけどもなんかすぐ人気なのが住んでるんですけど近くの
コンビニどこさらすともなくて非常に悔しいながらも四つしか買えませんでした
なんか可愛いね俺酔ってないよって仕方ね4つまで限界のお母様で連結させて超巨大な
組を作ってみようと思いますっていっぱいては連結させていきましょう
なんかは食べ物で遊ぶと食べ物で遊ぶなって言われる
るんですけども自ら遊びに行ってますからねこれどうやって連休させるんだろうって
連携ず後方でを残念だよ
効果幸田で連結しましたたぶんこういう感じでどんどん連結させていけばいいんだと
思います
マナが水本当にレンゲってるんだけどこれ大丈夫か連結部分が甘くてすごい不安になり
そうなんですけどやってみましょう
なんかしょーもねーなーこれ瀬谷のしょうもないんですけど麦2組がつながるってそう
そうないものだと思うんで結構画期的だと思うんですよね実用性はないですけど
はすごいちゃんと繋がってるこれちょっと量袋と馬鹿にしましたけど結構な中谷名湯
でしょ
[音楽]
はいというわけで一袋つなげましたいやすごいすごいすごい
あはいと言うべしすごいですねあの一袋だけでもこのサイズ感までなくなることが
分かりました
けっこうこれ長い人ってアジアじゃ
はい大丈夫ちょっと先不安になりましたができるできる僕の持ってる訓練みんな分で
連結させていければいいなと思っておりますでは
行くねー
[音楽]
というわけでできましたが長さ的にはでもまあ
1m ぐらい休んである1m ぐらいですねため1m 下旬との超えてるネジメートル
20センチくらいの長さにはなってるんじゃないなっかなと思いますからこれねを
つくってみて思ったんですけどもう一袋で別投げた瞬間を持ったのが弱気所にはワイン
でこれたぶんちょっと告示浮かさする壊れちゃうんすよね空中部が来ちゃうんですよと
感じちゃう真っ赤にしてもで多分持ち上げるすぐ腹が立ってなるのがもう目に見えてる
んですよ
あれ意外とイケる
この前に知っててちょっと強度を高めますかハンマーで叩けば祭な強度はますので
しっかり靴業前
かっクリ社はねぇ
はぁっ
[拍手]
その後私は訓練みんなの近況し続けついに5000メートルを超える組んでみんなの
開発に成功
その組んでミーナは大金を突破し火星に到達コース準備は訓練みんなを使って家庭で
生活するようになった
[音楽]
me
ああああああ
あっはぁ